- People love meeting you.
So have, I mean, I know
this 'cause I'm one of them.
But have you ever just completely
lost your mind and, like,
goofed out over one of your idols?
- Oh, all the time.
- Yeah.
- Every time Trisha Yearwood
walks through that door.
- Oh, good answer.
- Yeah, skins make, yeah.
It does, woo.
- She is the greatest vocalist.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] You know I'm a nerd for her.
- Her voice is like
the sound of crystal.
- Well, the crazy thing is
too, awards are only as good
as the people's name's that are on them.
Compliments are only good as
the people that give them.
And I tell you--
- Oh, you're nice,
you're nice.
- No, no, no,
you're, you're, you're a freak.
(Kelly laughing)
You're a freak of nature.
Everybody in the business knows it.
You have no ceiling.
You're so, for you to say that about her,
she would sit here and say the
exact same thing about you.
- Oh, she's the one I'd be
singing with the hairbrush.
- She loves you, man.
- Yes.